[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans checkup le
magazine santé de la rédaction ce
mois-ci nous irons à la MGEN pour
découvrir les travaux de reconstruction
nous nous intéresserons aussi à un
concours de cuisine proposé à des
personnes en situation de handicap nous
suivrons un atelier de rencontre pour
les aidents familiaux proposés par
gandicap mais d'abord le premier sujet
c'est de saison la protection solaire
alors le soleil ne brille pas toujours
et de façon intensive pourtant il faut
faire attention à sa peau car les
cancers de la peau sont en forte
augmentation ces dernières années tous
les conseils de
prévention le cancer de la peau 80000
nouveaux cas par an une pathologie en en
augmentation la raison les Français ne
font pas assez attention à leur niveau
de protection solaire à 38 ans Céline
buznet en a fait la merère expérience
c'est au cours d'une visite chez une
dermatologue qu'on lui détecte un basau
cellulaire un type de cancer de la peau
que l'on retrouve dans 90 % des cas on
m'a demandé si je m'exposais beaucoup au
soleil apparemment bon pas plus que ça
sauf effectivement pendant les les
périodes la période estivale où
effectivement donc il s'agirait plus de
de coup de soleil euh donc pris pendant
durant l'enfance
ou effectiv ou également
des une une exposition donc aux ultra
ultra violets donc les UV qui ne
seraient pas voilà qui seraient très
néfaste le soleil pour moi maintenant
c'est c'est fini je ne dois plus trop
voilà je ne dois plus m'exposer et et
puis effectivement me protéger également
donc chapeau lunettes de soleil tout ce
que
voilà les enfants et les personnes âgées
sont les plus fragiles face au soleil
un chapeau un t-shirt pour éviter les
coups de soleil et surtout un bon indice
de protection solaire entre 15 et 50
selon le type de peau attention
également aux idées reçues en ce moment
c'est certes nuageux et pourtant il faut
penser à se protéger lorsque le soleil
n'est pas là tout simplement on sort et
on se dit que les nuages couvrent un
petit peu les rayons ultraviolets du
soleil alors que aussi avec les nuages
il faut se se protéger les rayons
ultraviolets passent au travers des
nuages et même avec les nuages il faut
quand même mettre une protection solaire
évitez aussi les huiles qui accélèrent
le bronzage car elles ne contiennent
aucun indice de protection enfin si vous
observez votre peau et constatez un
grain de beauté qui change de forme et
d'aspect ne pas hésiter à consulter son
[Musique]
dermatologue un nouvel Espace Santé
Active ouvert en plein centre-ville de
Versailles 1 an après celui de poissier
quelques mois avant une autre ouverture
prévue à cuit en cours un lieu dédié à
la prévention plutôt qu'au soins et une
façon pour la CPM de réduire ses
dépenses de
santé un an après celui de poissi la CPM
des ivelines ouvre un nouvel Espace
Santé Active cette fois à Versailles
toujours le même concept prévenir plutôt
que guérir ici l'on propose à des
assurés sociaux en bonne santé des
informations pratiques et des ateliers
autour de trois thématiques le cœur le
dos et la nutrition un dernier thème qui
a convaincu Joël de s'inscrire je suis
venue un peu pour une alimentation
équilibrée pour euh refaire mon
mon mon alimentation maigrir aussi voilà
et il y a aussi atelier cuisine il y a
pas mal de choses qui m'intéresserait
donc euh le dos et la nourriture parce
que je ne sais pas
m'alimenter j'ai j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
mal il y a beaucoup de choses que je ne
supporte pas que je n'ai jamais supporté
si la nutrition a du succès un autre
thème intéresse c'est le mal de dos les
lombalgies sont par exemple les
premières causes médicales de
remboursement dans le département alors
donc prévenir plutôt que guérir prend
ici tout son sens le problème qu'on
constate souvent avec le mal de dos
c'est que quand on commence à s'en
préoccuper c'est parce qu'on a mal or
effectivement il y a des moyens de
prévenir le mal de dos qui sont
d'adopter des bonnes postures c'est
effectivement de renforcer son dos par
des exercices assez régulier de faire de
l'activité physique et tout ça ça permet
de prévenir le mal de dos mais
effectivement aujourd'hui on est souvent
en France dans une posture où on attend
d'avoir mal au dos avant de se
préoccuper de la santé de son dos la
documentation ainsi que les ateliers
sont gratuit il suffit juste d'être
assuré au régime général dans le
département des ivelines Santé Active
est ouvert le soir jusqu'à 19h et même
le samedi à poissi l'espace ouvert
depuis un an compte 1000 adhérents un
troisème pôle devrait ouvrir à guuill en
cour d'ici à la fin de
[Musique]
l'année
allez direction maintenant l'entreprise
Sodexo installée à Guill encour je vous
propose maintenant de suivre un concours
de cuisine pas comme les autres
puisqu'il est réservé aux personnes en
situation de
handicap faut qu'on enchaîne carpacho de
cœur de pastèque donc Stéphane je te
passe toutes faut tu les passes plutôt
une par une parce que ou ou ouais une
par une ça te va une par une bon on fait
une par une parce que là si tout ça je
te les dispose on se repère pas sur le
sur le plan de travail je suis d'accord
avec toi stéphane est atteint de trouble
de la mémoire et manque de repè spatiau
temporel encouragé par son éducateur il
prépare sa recette de dessert baptisée
au Monière gourmande car ce mardi
c'était la finale nationale du concours
culinaire pour personnes handicapées
organisé par la Société Sodexo et lui ce
qu' voulait c'était travailler en
cuisine faire de la pâtisserie donc on a
essayé de de faire en sorte par ce biais
du concours qui qui metettent un pied on
va dire dans la pâtisserie ou dans le
travail à proprementandit quoi sur 115
équipes inscrites au départ il n restait
plus que 7 pour cette ultime épreuve à
laquelle participai des collaborateurs
de l'entreprise basée à guillencour il
travaillent beaucoup ils ont travaillé
depuis le mois de février mars sur sur
leurs recettees et ils sont très
impliqués allez on enchaîne super bon
allez on va dresser les assiettes je
suis obligé de de suivre les consignes
de de de de
de Greg et de d'Abdel donc je suis
obligé de suivre leur conseil donc pour
parce que trouvent que j'étais un peu
motivé mais au début il pensais que
j'avais un peu le trac et tout ça que
j'étais un peu perdu après 2 heures
d'épreuve il est temps de présenter ses
créations aux membres du jury c'est beau
ça pe influencer sur le bon à manger
d'accord voilà première chose et puis
après bon il y avait une thématique
c'était sur les fleurs on les respectter
pu maintenant on va goûter on va voir si
on voyage dans l'univers
j'espère que tout le monde croisera les
doigts pour moi parce que j'espère que
franchement je voudrais bien que tout le
monde me soutienne c'est ma passion et
donc c'est c'est un truc qui me touche
vraiment vraiment au cœur si Stéphane
n'a pas remporté la finale de ce
concours il espère devenir un jour
commis de
[Musique]
cuisine les aidents familaux ce sont
souvent ceux dont on ne parle pas ce
sont ceux qui soutiennent ou
accompagnent un père une mère un mari ou
une femme souffrante l'association
girant Handicap a proposé des rencontres
autour d'échanges et de conseil et ces
rencontres ont eu lieu dans une
brasserie à Montini loin de tout cadre
médical dans une brasserie au cœur de la
ville des rencontres d'un nouveau type
ils aident un père une mère un mari
souffrant ce sont des aidents l'occasion
leur a été donnée pour la première fois
d'échanger et de raconter en dehors d'un
cadre médical des café rencontres
proposé par le groupe manger handicap
Michel Druard s'occupe au quotidien de
de son mari qui souffre d'une forme de
la maladie d'Alzheimer et quand je dis
je sens démuni c'est ce point de vue là
quoi c'est pas physiquement ni
matériellement ni comme ça mais
psychiquement je suis très fatiguée le
fait de voir des gens qui ont des
problèmes comparables voir voir pire ça
ça ne soulage pas mais ça ça on se sent
moins seul voilà on se sent accompagné
accompagné et soutenu Marie-Claude de
joubar aide son père depuis 10 ans elle
est venue délivrer des conseils se faire
aider au maximum quand on peut et voilà
se détacher c'est pas toujours facile ça
prend du temps parce que bah on est
toujours très attaché au sien ben j'ai
appris à savoir me détacher à lâcher
prise ça c'est c'est très important
lâcher prise s'offrir des plages de
respiration dépasser la peur du malfire
et surtout connaître ses
limites donc puisque aid dans naturel ou
familial c'est c'est donc quelqu'un qui
est en relation de famille avec
quelqu'un d'autre
et d'un seul coup il va être sollicité
pour des relations qui ne seront plus de
type familial classique mais des
relations de de type fonctionnel donc où
est la limite quand est-ce qu'il est
l'époux ou le fils et quand est-ce qu'il
est en train de
l'aider dans telle ou telle tâche
l'ensemble des professionnels présents à
G handicap ont relevé des besoins de
soutien des aidents des besoins
d'échange de de parole des besoins de
convivialité aussi ces rencontres
gratuites sont prévu tous les 15 jours
au mois de septembre des groupes de
parole se mettront en
[Musique]
place les bâtiments de la MG à La
Verrière seront reconstruits et
accueilleront sur un même site le ple
psychiatrie et la gériatrie un projet
d'envergure qui va aussi bénéficier à la
population puisque le parc sera ouvert
au public
explication structure obsolète et coup
d'entretien trop important pour ces
bâtiments qui datent de 959 la décision
est tombée les hôpitaux de la verrière
seront reconstruits la MGEN propriétaire
du site a validé le projet en avril
dernier les pavillons d'hébergement de
l'Institut Marcel Rivière seront donc
rasés à la place trois bâtiments devrai
être construits pour accueillir les
services de santé mentale et le centre
gériatrique deis forestier pour un total
de 107 nouveaux lits il ne manque que
l'accord de l'agence régionale de santé
avant de lancer les travaux d'ici fin
2014 malgré le rapport alarmant de la
inspection générale des finances qui a
récemment pointé du doigt l'endettement
des hôpitaux publics la direction
s'estime confiante aujourd'hui nous
sommes un établissement qui n'est pas en
déficit qui est juste
équilibré notre but c'est de péreniser
cet équilibre or on sait avec les études
logistiques et
architecturales que si on ne fait rien
on pourra pas maintenir cet équilibre
donc on a voulu anticiper les ce
problème là et péréniser un en équilibre
voire dégager des excédents qui seront
de toute façon réinvestis dans la prise
en charge des patients ces travaux vont
aussi changer le quotidien des habitants
puisque le parc du château ouvrira au
public quatre entrées sont prévues
notamment du côté d'Orly parc les
quartiers de la gare et du village
pourrait ainsi être relié d'ici la
rentrée une ouverture qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre du projet de réhabilitation de
la zone
garbécan nous allons urbaniser une
partie des terrains des bécanes qui
étaient des espaces naturels c'est vrai
et donc quelque part c'est comme si nous
compensions une urbanisation de nouveaux
terrains qui sont des terrains naturels
aujourd'hui peu utiliser il ser pas la
promenade donc par la
restitution publique d'un parc boisé la
ville a d'ailleurs organisé un
pique-nique géant fin juin l'occasion
pour les verriersrois de découvrir en
avant-première ce parc de 22
[Musique]
hectares
checkup le magazine santé de la
rédaction c'est terminé pour cette
saison c'était d'ailleurs la 150e
émission rien que cela une émission donc
qui a de l'âge mais qui se porte bien
rendez-vous en septembre pour de
nouveaux reportages d'ici là surtout
profitez bien de votre été à très vite
sur TVfil
[Musique]